Was man bei all dem verstehen
muss: Es geht nicht mehr
darum zu verhindern,
dass Menschen mit dem Virus
zusammen kommen. Das ist eine
Pandemie, sie ist nicht mehr
zu stoppen. Fachleute
gehen nach allem, was sie
wissen davon aus, dass etwa zwei Drittel
der Deutschen mit
dem Virus in Kontakt
kommen werden - und erkranken.
Die allermeisten von ihnen -
80 Prozent - sehr leicht und leicht.
20 Prozent werden ärztliche Hilfe
brauchen und etwa Sechs Prozent
intensivmedizinische Betreuung.
Sechs Prozent - das klingt nicht nach
viel, sind aber mehr als
eine Million Menschen.
Wenn man jetzt zulässt,
dass sich die Viren so
exponentiell rasant verbreiten,
wie sie es von Natur aus tun,
dann werden sie Pflege und
Kliniken und Ärzte überwältigen.
Es kommt darauf an,
den Verlauf dieser Kurve
zu strecken, dass sich
die Ansteckungswelle
möglichst weit über das Jahr verteilt.
Dann werden immer noch genauso
viele Menschen krank,
aber eben nach und nach.
das Geschehen beruhigt sich
und alle können die
maximale Hilfe moderner
Medizin bekommen. Das ist im
Moment das Ziel,
so wenig wie möglich Ansteckung
jetzt am Anfang und deshalb
ist scheinbarer
Kleinkram wie Händewaschen
Abstand halten, keine Partys
machen lebenswichtig. Nicht
nur für einen selbst,
sondern vor allem für die
Schwächsten in dieser hoffentlich
langen Kurve.